le salon des vieux papiers qui se tient
à l'ancienne gare de la bastille a
décidé cette année de mettre un peu de
piquant dans sa traditionnelle
ordonnance les organisateurs ont
dépoussiéré les vieux papiers et choisi
un nouveau thème l'érotisme népotisme
parfois rétro mais qui trouve là son
premier festival alors un peu curieuse
corinne lalo s'est rendu à l'ancienne
gare de la bastille voici les images et
les impressions qu'elle en a rapporté
à
et
je
kim
c'est toi
0,6 c'est quoi le moitié des à billère
je ne sais pas répondre à ça se passe et
ce qu'on rencontre dans la vie parfois
c'est en érotisme c'est une certaine
choses cachées les folies vous c'est
quoi érotisme je ne sais pas je m'en
fous souvient déficit ne doit pas encore
réussi à convaincre de finition mais si
vous en avez une âme fond de votre
château avec plaisir qui est très
important
charpy dans le champ
et
érotisme définition du dictionnaire
vient du grec héros ce qui concerne
l'amour vous marquez excessif ou
pathologique pour les choses sexuelles
paris 1er festival de l'érotisme des
photos des tableaux de la lingerie mais
aussi des radios librement alors
l'installons dans les reprises fait bien
on a inventé beaucoup de coups d'oeil le
coup d'oeil discret bien sûr sur
certaines choses et d'autres moins
discrets alors il ya il ya pas mal de
faux mais il y a aussi des comment
dirais-je des pâtisseries
oui d'ailleurs à reparler mais qui sont
fort intéressants qu'est ce que c'est
c'est sans doutes et fantasmes que
manche et que vous pensez érotique c'est
un gaillard au pti je crois que les
antilles mais complètement dans la tête
des champs c'est à dire que tous ceux
qui viennent ici trouver ce qu'ils
cherchent peut-être qu'ils inventent
mais peut-être qu'un festival érotique
mais pas érotique du tout d'abord voilà
jusqu'à